et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
adrien 80's bonjour merci beaucoup nous
députés du nord coordinateur de la
france insoumise en est ensemble pendant
20 minutes - d'interviews en partenariat
avec la presse quotidienne régionale
représenté par julien lizeroux de la
voix du nord bonjour bonjour monsieur
dit bonjour et grecs latins sont
commence par la crise sanitaire puisque
on est aujourd'hui dans une nouvelle
phase de levée des restrictions avec de
nouvelles restrictions qui sont donc
levés on va pouvoir rpt consommer de
boue dans les bars dans les récents à
pouvoir retourner dans les concerts de
vous on va pouvoir retourner en boîte de
nuit ce soir si on le souhaite mais la
situation est elle reste tendue
gabriella talent l'a dit hier et l'appel
à la prudence est ce que du coup le
gouvernement a raison d'attendre avant
de lever d'autres mesures dont plusieurs
choses d'abord le fait de retrouver dans
pas mal de domaines une forme de liberté
c'était plus que nécessaire je le crois
ça fait depuis maintenant près de deux
ans qu'on s'évertue à dire que
d'ailleurs je crois qu'on n'en a pas
complètement fini avec l'épidémie tout
le monde le voit et qu'il faut créer les
conditions d'une vie la plus normale
possible en adaptant des méthodes qui
permettent de vivre et donc pas de
rester confinés où avec toutes ces
établissements fermés de vivre en
limitant la circulation du virus avec
des protocoles et tout le reste on est
clairement aujourd'hui on peut se dire
les choses il est urgent maintenant de
d'abroger le pass vaccinale qui n'a plus
de sens qui n'a pas d'efficacité du
point de vue de la jugulation d'épidémie
donc le gouvernement serait bien inspiré
de le faire et de le faire dès
maintenant c'est pas trop tôt monsieur k
danse parce que concrètement le gabriel
attal a aussi rappelé que même s'il ya
une décrue dans lits dans les hôpitaux
les seuils restent élevés et surtout on
continue d'avoir des déprogrammations du
fait de la saturation des services mais
j'ai envie presse de vous retourner la
question pourquoi ce serait trop tôt
quelle efficacité le pass vaccinale en
tant que tel apporte aujourd'hui alors
c'est votre blonde épidémie c'est votre
grand argument de dire en effet que
passe d'accès n'a hélas n'a aucune
utilité c'est à dire que les sexes mais
c'est à dire que nous on reste sur la
ligne de l'organisation mondiale de la
santé s'agissant du jeu accents nous
sommes favorables à la vaccination
considérant que le vaccin 20 mais
limiter les formes graves par contre
tout le monde et nous trois on peut
s'accorder là-dessus ce matin tout le
monde voit bien que même vacciner
beaucoup à trappes l'aco vide donc du
point de vue de la limitation de la
circulation du virus oui mais non
vaccinés sur occupent les services de
réanimation mais où qu'il faille faire
la promotion du vaccin pour limiter des
formes graves du virus dont acte j'en ai
dirait on y participe en revanche c'est
que simplement le fait de dire aux gens
de faire appel à leur intelligence des
noms de vacciner leur dire de les
convaincre de passer du temps ça suffira
plus que le passé vaccinale en tout cas
ce que je sais c'est un une prise de
position politique qui est alignée sur
la position de l'organisation mondiale
de la santé je vous le redis c'est que
on ne contraint pas à la vaccination en
l'espèce ce n'est pas efficace il faut
en effet convaincre
si vous aussi vous vous supporter l'idée
que des gens se soient rendus dans des
centres de vaccination peut-être parfois
sans être pour le coup convaincu de la
nécessité de se faire vacciner mais
simplement pour obtenir un document qui
permettent de l'art avoir une vie
d'avoir une vie moins contrainte nous
pensons que c'est une c'est une erreur
voilà et surtout aujourd'hui on le voit
avec l'apparition des variants notamment
le dernier en date au micron dire crâne
bardon mais vous avez vous avez autour
de vous j'en suis sûr des tas de gens
comme c'est mon cas qui ont eu la
troisième dose et qui malgré tout
attrape le virus donc on continue à
faire la promotion du vaccin pour
limiter les formes graves mais tout le
monde voit bien aujourd'hui que le
vaccin à lui seul n'est pas la solution
pas rappelez vous quand même que
monsieur vers ans au sein de l'hémicycle
nous avait dit quand on sera vacciné y
aura plus de problème il y aura plus de
virus tout le monde voit que ça n'est
pas le cas de la même manière un peu
plus tôt quand vous rembobinez le film
vous aviez monsieur vers ans qui disait
ah non le pass sanitaire jamais on
pourrait pas monsieur vers ans qui
disait ça on pourrait pas imaginer qu'en
france on est à présenter des données de
santé pour aller au restaurant bon
c'était monsieur verrons si vous voulez
les meilleurs arguments contre les
passes vaccinaux sanitaire écoutez
monsieur macro et messieurs vers en
avant qu'eux-mêmes décide de le mettre
en place et surtout lorsqu'ils l'ont mis
en place ils ont bien dit que ce serait
extrêmement temporaire ça ne l'est plus
aujourd'hui ça c'est prolonger le pacte
d'actionnaires a priori la paix le pass
vaccinale sera donc enlevé dès lors que
les les indicateurs sanitaires bien sûr
ils ont peu varié à vous et moi je viens
de cliquer peut-être les indicateurs
mais seront positifs juste avant
l'élection présidentielle par exemple
mois d'avril ce serait donc une oeuvre
politique alors oui je le crois les donc
c'est la raison pour laquelle je dis je
ne suis pas le seul à dire que le pass
vaccinale peut être abrogée maintenant
d'autant plus que depuis le 15 février
c'est je crois plus de 5 millions de
personnes qui se retrouvent en
difficulté pour pouvoir circuler
librement il ya d'autres moyens on peut
faire toutes les missions là dessus je
peux vous reparler ce que vous agissez
qu'on vous en parle tout le temps mais
je peux vous reparler des purificateurs
d'air de l'installation de la société
par roulement de la multiplication des
protocoles sanitaires tout ce que nous
avons proposé il ya d'autres moyens de
juguler l'épidémie que d'avoir ce type
de passe liberticide et de ce point de
vue je le dis les convois de la liberté
qu'on a vu se développer notamment le
week-end dernier et bien doivent être
soutenus sur ses revendications celles
de l'abrogation du pass vaccinale parce
que souvent il ya de la confusion 1 on
prête à toutes les personnes qui luttent
contre le passo contre les mesures
liberticides des penchants anti-vaccins
pardon mais pour avoir gardé ça de près
vous avez plein de gens là dedans qui
sont vaccinés et qu'ils disent
simplement on en
mais qu'on nous on meurt pour la
dissolution de parler de politique
vis-à-vis de ce que fait le gouvernement
clément bonne nuit là dessus vous accuse
de réponse de récupération très bon
d'abord la présidente une chose qui est
très net c'est que bien mal inspiré qui
peut croire que de tels mouvements
soient récupérables on a l'expérience
des gilet jaune et d'ailleurs c'est très
bien comme ça j'ai envie de dire peu
importe mon avis la vie de jean luc
mélenchon des politiques pour ces
mouvements ça n'a aucune espèce
d'importance parce que précisément ils
veulent se prévenir toute forme de
récupération politique en revanche
lorsque je suis interrogé je vois des
convois qui demandent l'abrogation du
pass vaccinale il se trouve que si nous
étions aux affaires à cette heure nous
l'aurions déjà abrogé
deuxièmement je vois des femmes et des
hommes qui luttent pour la question du
pouvoir d'achat qui nous paraît centrale
qui est la première préoccupation des
français donc évidemment je les soutiens
sur les bases de
bain je ne le crois pas non parce que en
effet les gilet jaune qui se sont
mobilisés qui ont été réprimées et
d'ailleurs le gouvernement continue
cette logique de répression quand vous
voyez le sort qui a été
réservé ce week end à jérôme rodriguez
par exemple c'est à dire un harcèlement
judiciaire et figurent déjà sur un homme
qui s'engagent tout ça montre que
monsieur macro n'a pas changé de méthode
et il ne faut pas qu'il s'y trompe même
si les gilet jaune sont retournés
davantage dans les boîtes à gants que
sur les ronds points dans ces dernières
semaines ces derniers mois cette france
des délaissés qui lutte pour son pouvoir
d'achat ces gens qui bossent qui
n'arrivent pas à joindre les deux bouts
malgré le fait qu'ils travaillent tous à
rejaillit sur tout pardon mais dans un
contexte où vous voyez exploser les
profits du cac 40 alors je sais que
c'est un peu traditionnelle de recevoir
un responsable politique de gauche
radicale qui vous parle des profits du
cac 40 mais si on peut s'y arrêter juste
un instant les records qui ont été
atteints en pleine crise sanitaire sont
exceptionnels on parle de 137 milliards
de profits pour les multinationales du
cac 40 70 milliards de dividendes versés
aux actionnaires et si vous voulez
l'effet de la politique de monsieur
macron notamment de la politique fiscale
c'est qu'on se retrouve dans une france
où cinq personnes cinq milliardaire
possède autant que 27 millions de
français 40 % de la population voilà la
réalité qu'on a sous les yeux et il se
trouve que nous mis en avant quelques
chiffres jumeaux qui doivent pouvoir
vous intéresser par exemple on nous dit
on vérifie que les milliardaires ont
accru leur patrimoine pendant la crise
sanitaire de 240 milliards d'euros là
vous dites mais 240 milliards d'euros
c'est peu ou prou ce que l'état a
dépensé et 240 milliards d'euros l'état
cédera kobryn pour les idées pour les
pour les aides qu'ovide de la même
manière quand on nous parle du déficit
de l'état c'est à peu près 140 milliards
et toutes sortes de personnages tout à
fait important disent qu'il faut réduire
le déficit de l'état 140 milliards c'est
à peu près le montant du cic le crédit
d'impôt recherche et toutes les aides
directes versées aux entreprises
que certains s'enrichissent dans ces
proportions quand les français ont du
mal à payer leur essence à payer leurs
factures donc il nous faut en effet une
grande loi d'urgence sorcières est
compris en effet votre votre point de
vue sur sûr cela alors puisqu'on parlait
des profits du du cac40 ça me fait une
transition toute trouvée avec orpea
c'est donc cette entreprise qui gère les
guetta hélas à l'origine des de la
sphère des ehpad le sénat a lancé une
commission d' enquête après la
révélation du scandale mais l'assemblée
s'y refuse qu'est ce que vous en pensez
côté nous nous avons signé avec le
groupe la france insoumise avec d'autres
groupes une tribune appelant à une
commission denquête pour la raison que
l'auteur du livre les fossoyeurs nous
l'ad'ailleurs bien dit en audition à
l'assemblée dit si vous n'avez pas de
commission denquête avec les pouvoirs d
une commission d enquête vous
n'obtiendrez pas de réponse j'ai
participé hier soir encore à une
audition d'un des membres du trio
à l'origine du système orpea l'un des
dirigeants très franchement on a
l'impression qu'on serait pris à une
enquête judiciaire qui est bien sûr
qu'ils sont qui sont déposées bien sûr
ils aiment d'une commission d' enquête
parlementaire c'est que quand elle se
fait en même temps qu'une enquête
judiciaire
c'est toujours assez compliqué de
l'amener on l'a vu déjà avec la ferme et
nalout mais le sujet étant éminemment
politique évidemment qu'on a besoin
d'une commission d'enquêté parlementaire
dont d'ailleurs les investigations
pourraient tout à fait complété les
investissements trop tard parce qu'on
arrive en coûts de cession de la
majorité présidentielle bah je ne les
explique pas bien c'est à dire que si je
peux l'expliquer d'une certaine manière
c'est que indépendamment de la
responsabilité des chefs d'orchestre
d'orpea que se livrent à câble il faut
en contexte politique favorable à ce
genre de situation vous savez il ya des
politiques publiques qui ont accompagné
les privatisations de noé pas d'être
notre système de santé
au delà du gouvernement même les
gouvernements précédents tous celles et
ceux qui ont accompagné ce mouvement de
privatisation qui ont permis que la
santé devienne un business que ce soit à
l'hôpital où que ce soit dans les ehpad
évidemment une récente finaliste le tout
le secteur des on a pas parler de
nationalisation on a parlé de
collectivisation c'est à dire on arrête
en tout cas avec le caractère lucratif
voilà parce que c'est en effet sa la
principale difficulté c'est à dire que
quand vous regardez ce qui a été fait
pour orpea est ce que révèle ce livre
bon on parle de taux d'encadrement
extrêmement faible ça fait des années
que c'est dénoncer on parle de
rationnement sur la nourriture sur les
couches on parle donc de nos anciens que
parfois on laisse dans leurs excréments
pendant toute une nuit ça c'est plutôt
agents et qui ne sont pas correctement
soignés c'est un problème de jeu de
contre mais il faut aussi des moyens
pour le contrôle parce que ça a été dit
et la rs l'a dit dans dans l'audition
parfois on a un manque de moyens pour
rendre les contrôles effectifs en tout
cas il n'est pas supportable et je pense
que personne ne peut le supporter que
l'on fasse du business sur le dos de nos
anciens il y avait un slogan que moi
j'aime bien mais qui est juste c'est nos
mamies valent plus que leurs profits ça
suffit de faire de l'argent en tout et
pour tout et y compris sur la santé des
gens ou sur ces pauvres familles on va
passer à une autre qualité atteint 4,1
cesser le choix de richard ferrand pour
le conseil constitutionnel qui fait
quelque peu polémique alors valais il a
choisi valérie malbec dont le monde a
révélé qu'elle était là supérieur
hiérarchique du procureur de brest qui a
classé sans suite l'enquêté préliminaire
sur les mutuel de bretagne dans laquelle
richard ferrand été mise en cause
richard ferrand s'en défend il a publié
hier soir un communiqué il dit qu'elle
n'a pas classé la procédure et il dit
c'est attenter à mon honneur que de
faire croire que d'autres motivations
que l'intérêt du respect de notre
constitution république dès mon choix
dans cette proposition de nomination
qu'est ce que vous en pensez j'ai pas
énormément d'avis là dessus vu de
l'extérieur en tout cas ça donne une
impression désagréable de la république
des copains quoi c'est très clair de la
même manière le fait de recaser madame
bourreau dans une instance juridique les
manuels tout ça ne donne pas une très
bonne impression je crois que je crois
que c'est encore une signification du
caractère en quelque sorte monarchique
de la vème république une ministre du
gouvernement n'a pas sa place au conseil
constitutionnel je ne le crois pas non
parce que ça donne cette impression de
recasage qui n'est pas très agréable je
crois que c'est pas une chose à faire et
que ce n'est pas un bon signal envoyé à
nos concitoyens cours à jacqueline
gourault à travers tous les mandats
locaux et aux gouvernements parcours il
justifie pas ces bas son savoir en tant
que tel c'est je vous dis cette
impression que quelques-uns d'entre eux
décident de la place des uns et des
autres voilà
non mais je encore une fois je n'ai pas
regardé le détail donc je peux pas me
prononcer plus avant mais je vu de
l'extérieur c'est une impression
désagréable
oui alors on peut espérer que les bruits
de bottes à la frontière ukrainienne
s'estompe quelque peu ces jours
prochains il ya eu des signes en tout
cas d'accalmie qui doivent être
vérifiées diddy l'elysée est-ce qu'on
peut quand même saluer les efforts
diplomatiques de la france dans cette
histoire je vois que vous déployez pas
mal d'efforts pour qu'on salue les
efforts du gouvernement qu'elle quitte
quelle que soit la situation n'en
coûtait bon d'abord une chose l'ambiance
médiatique qui tous les quatre matins
nous annonce une invasion
l'ukraine par la russie participe
finalement de la situation comparée des
cent cinquante mille hommes à la
frontière est bien vrai qu'il ya aucun
aucun signe s'il ya des signes oui mais
le fait que le gouvernement ukrainien
lui même et que les responsables
ukrainiens eux mêmes disent depuis des
semaines
entre guillemets calmez-vous savent
habitera se passe et ce que fait la
france aussi diane on attendait en dix
ans
le gouvernement ukrainien disait encore
clairement et à quelques jours que n'y
avait pas de risque imminent d'invasion
d'accord c'est les responsables
ukrainiens qu'il en est ce que c'est pas
aussi une position pour éviter l'
escalade non puisque c'est ce qui est
clairement dit par le gouvernement
ukrainien comme que balla par le
gouvernement français c'est à dire que
plus vous vous appelez au feu comme les
prennent d'ailleurs les etats-unis et
plus vous risquez l'escaladent coûté la
menace est là vous pouvez pas dire le
contraire mais ce qui est en jeu ce qui
est en jeu dans cette affaire c'est à
dire que quand on regarde un peu les
médias et la manière dont il traite le
sujet c'est on a d'un côté les gentils
américains de l'autre côté les méchants
russes qui veulent envahir l'ukraine bon
supporter que la situation soit pas
aussi simple que ça et on préalable je
vais vous dire une chose pour ce soit
très clair parce que dès qu'on a une
position qui n'est pas alignée sur le
discours dominant des médias on nous
fait le procès de dire ah oui mais de
façon vous êtes ambiguë vous soutenez le
nom mais
c'est à dire que le sujet sur place le
sujet sur place c'est la question de
l'extension de l'otan plus avant
toujours à l'est voilà c'est la question
que pose la question c'est de la
question de la souveraineté de l'ukraine
non ça c'est ce que vous vous dites mais
ça n'est pas que sa création sur place
non ce n'est pas que ça non ce n'est pas
que ça mais par contre vous accepter
l'idée que dans les médias on parle ma
tribu russe le point de vue russe en
effet c'est la question de la de l'ac2a
sécurité mais à dire de l'extension en
effet le jeu et que c'est à lui et c'est
le coeur de la faire c'est le coeur de
la fait rare pas que ben écoutez si
c'est le coeur de la faire moi je vous
le dit c'est à dire que pourquoi et pour
répondre à votre question sur
l'efficacité de la diplomatie française
dans l'art il a d'abord préalable jean
luc mélenchon la france insoumise n'est
pas un soutien du régime russe
quand jean luc mélenchon se déplace en
russie il rencontre sergueï oudaltsov un
opposant à vladimir poutine responsable
du front de gauche russe qui a
d'ailleurs passé des années de sa vie en
prison d'accord donc ça c'est la
première chose notre position à nous
c'est une position de non alignement
nous voulons une france indépendante au
service de la paix or et je gère donc à
votre réponse quand monsieur macron
essaye d'aller au kremlin joué les
entremetteurs mais que dans le même
temps il est pris entre plein de
contradictions le fait d'un côté de dire
je veux participer à la désescalade je
veux me faire l'intermédiaire en quelque
sorte mais dans le même temps dans sa
position de président du conseil
européen montrer les muscles pour dire
on a besoin d'installer cette puissance
européenne arrimé à l'otan quand
monsieur macron est au kremlin et que
dans le même temps monsieur biden et
monsieur jones se réunissent pour eux à
porter un discours qui plutôt fait
monter les tensions avec l'histoire du
'pipeline' voyait bien que la france
dans tout ça et d'ailleurs la
diplomation la diplomatie russe ne s'y
trompe pas son efficacité et à ses
proches
emmanuel macron a servi à rien ab je
crois que c'est essentiellement une
gesticulation qui permet monsieur macron
aussi de faire sa campagne électorale
mais que l'efficacité d'ailleurs la
diplomatie russe ne dit pas autre chose
que l'efficacité est assez limité et au
juste une chose la position notre
position pour soient très claires et et
vous allez voir qu'elle est équilibrée
cette position consiste à dire entendez
moi bien la russie n'a pas à envahir
l'ukraine j'espère avoir exemple vient
de rappeler oui je je je déplore que ce
soit nécessaire de le rappeler mais je
vous le dis la russie n'a pas enlevé à
l'ukraine mais les états unis n'ont pas
non plus à annexer l'ukraine dans l'otan
voilà voilà ce qu'il faut dire et donc
la position de la dîmière poutine
simplement de dire mais en quelque sorte
il demande des garanties légales écrite
sur le fait que l'otan cesse de
s'étendre toujours plus avant à l'est
c'est tout l'ukraine inquiet d'un pays
ouvrez donc a le droit de demander son
entrée dans le pardon mais vous savez
très bien que le fond géopolitique de la
faire c'est que les états unis
d'amérique qui sont en déclin économique
qui jouent leur guerre face à la chine
et la russie
qui sont celles basées sur un
déploiement militaire tous azimuts
l'otan ces mille 1000 milliards de
dépenses militaires vous le savez très
bien les deux la présidence oui autres
petites affaires qui doit se résoudre
dans les mois prochains alors vous avez
noté comme moi un atelier retour donc la
candidate de lutte ouvrière à 0 % dans
les intentions de vote à l'heure
actuelle dispose de ses 500 signatures
vous n'en avait récolté que 3 132 et ce
qu'est une inquiétude oui je vais pas là
surjouée le travail est bien fait il est
bien maîtrisée par des gens qui s'en
occupent mais oui c'est difficile on l'a
dit je le répète est temps que nous n'y
serons pas nous ne relâcherons pas
l'intensité de nos efforts quand vous
dites on n'aura peut-être pas les 500
parrainages mais c'est une hypothèse
c'est une hypothèse c'est pourquoi le
travail à l'heure où je vous parle il se
poursuit parce que en effet les délais
sont très rapprochées et la difficulté
je crois beaucoup de candidats
s'accordent à le dire s'est accrue les
élus les maires n'ont pas demandé ce
pouvoir voilà ils ne l'ont pas demandé
et ils doivent jouer ce rôle qui est
important et sans nécessairement engagé
de grandes discussions et son conseil
municipal est tout autre chose faut
rappeler une chose essentielle c'est
qu'un élu qui parraine n'est pas un
soutien politique vous avez des élus de
droite qui ne partagent à peu près rien
du programme l'avenir en commun qui
parraine jean luc mélenchon pour la
raison qu'il leur paraîtraient
absolument incroyable qu'un candidat qui
a fait 7 millions de voix la dernière
présidentielle ne puisse pas se ferait
appel m qui projette peut-être une
banque des parrainages un bf merci votre
bon maître jeudi à monsieur bayrou
j'espère qu'on arrivera à se débrouiller
sans son aide parce que j'aurais aimé
que les élus du modem vote à l'assemblée
nationale pour notre proposition de loi
sur la solution à 150000 parrainage
citoyen ce qu'ils n'ont pas fait alors
arrivé une fois les difficultés pour
dire on va vous sauver c'est très gentil
mais on aimerait plus écarté assez
d'accord ok bon bassin
les sondes est oui alors je lui
mélenchon malgré ce déficit de signature
malgré tout il ya une poussée il ya une
dînette dynamique il est donné entre 10
et 13 dans l'est dans les derniers
sondages
est-ce que vous rêvez d'une dynamique
similaire à 2017 je crois que les
ingrédients sont réunis pour que ça se
reproduise il y en a deux des
ingrédients le premier c'est un effet
efficacité du vote à gauche c'est à dire
en gros des trains et lecteur une
lectrice de gauche voulait véritablement
en finir que quinquennal monsieur macron
vous êtes intéressé par tout ce qu'on
propose le partage des richesses la
relance de l'activité et l'emploi la
planification écologique la 6ème
république vous dites en effet
aujourd'hui il ya clairement un vote
efficace qui apparaît dans le paysage
dans le tableau où la qualification au
second tour
second tour dont je rappelle que
aujourd'hui il est aux alentours de 16
17 % le seuil du jouet le soleil ne sait
plus très loin quand on est donné entre
10 et 13% quand même un ingrédient
attendait
avec vous là fabien roussel il est aussi
dans une dynamique il se rapproche des
5% est ce que est ce qu'il est en train
de voler la vedette à germer témoin
juste de finir ma réponse premier
ingrédient la question d'efficacité du
vote deuxième ingrédient le niveau de la
participation populaire le dernier
sondage qui donne jean luc mélenchon en
progression à 11 et demi je crois c'est
un sondage sur 63 % de participation et
je crois qu'on devrait toutes et tous
interroger davantage la participation
quand les sondages sont publiés la
dernière présidentielle je crois que
c'est 78 % de participation et on sait
que plus la participation populaire
progresse plus notamment jean luc
mélenchon en bénéficient parce que notre
électorat et est davantage touchée par
l'absence qu'il faut qu'ils votent a et
b et c'est tout le travail qu'on aime
c'est à dire vous voyez et on voit dans
les meetings le monde qu'il y ait ces
mais à tout le travail qui est mené
chaque jour sur le terrain pour aller
dans les quartiers les plus à 100
sioniste chacun d'ailleurs c'est
l'occasion de rappeler on va parler très
bien rousset s'est rassuré en prêt mais
ce que je veux dire c'est que par
exemple le fait qu' on est jusqu'au 4
mars pour s'inscrire sur liste
électorale il faudrait à chaque émission
appelée donc là on le dit à ce que ces
malins avaient voté et vous
il serait bien temps et avec des moyens
parce que franchement à quelques jours
du scrutin il serait plus que temps donc
inscrivez vous sur listes électorales
avant le 4 mars parce que les électeurs
de monsieur macro où ils seront
mobilisés si vous voulez que ça change
il faut le faire voilà donc vous devez
en fait l'idée c'est de vote utile si
vous voulez voter vizier dutil moi je
m'arme efficacité serait utile c'est
aussi connoté et ça donne l'impression
tout le monde est inutile autour oui
mais enfin c'est de la phraséologie mais
n'empêche que sa réalisation mais la
réponse sur fabien roussel du foot mais
je peux que déplorer le fait que ce qui
a été possible en 2012 et 2017 non sans
un certain succès ne le soit plus en
2022 je vais vous dire franchement je
pense que bon il est connu pour sa
franchise fabien roussel moi aussi en
novembre 2020 on discute tous les deux
dans le train entre lille et paris comme
ça nous arrive souvent on partage
certains diagnostics mais pas tous il me
dit moi je crois que 2022 s'est perdue
pour la gauche je dis c'est dommage de
considérer les choses comme ça il m'a
dit je vous demande de respecter les
insoumis que j'irai jusqu'au bout sauf
me dit il peut-être que je re miserait
mon choix si d'aventuré il y avait
véritablement une opportunité pour la
gauche de se qualifier au second tour je
lui dit très calmement fabien quand tu
regarde aujourd'hui les sondages
le bloc populaire que nous incarnions en
2012 ou en 2017 même si je vois qu'il
fait beaucoup d'efforts pour essayer de
se distinguer mais le bloc population
pour présenter ses vous connaissez le
black-out présentons aujourd'hui si vous
additionnez attendait si vous
additionnez aujourd'hui le niveau de
jean luc mélenchon dans les sondages et
les 3 4% de fabien roussel on est à la
baisse qu'il faudrait pas arrêter la
guéguerre le fait est que on a
l'impression à l'heure actuelle sont
jean-luc mélenchon est nourri quelques
guéguerre que se soit à ses concurrents
je clame alors dans l'est il ya des
choses qui essaient de paraissent assez
incompatibles est ce que concrètement
vous pouvez rêver d'une alliance avec
fabien roussel qui défend le nucléaire
qui défend une une fermeté sur sur rôle
régalien ce qu'il est juste compatible
avec jean luc mélenchon
j'ai l'impression qu'on n'est pas fermes
sur le régalien on n'a pas un programme
le nucléaire
c'est clair que si son but c'est de se
distinguer à tout prix par toutes sortes
de sortie qu'on peut parfois jugée
excessive ça peut rendre les choses
complexes mais pour le coup fabien
roussel sait bien qu'en 2012 ou en 2017
les communistes avaient aussi dans leur
programme le nucléaire et qu'on avait
trouvé un moyen de régler la question ça
s'appelle
la question du nucléaire ne nous a pas
empêchés de travailler ensemble en 2012
en 2017 voilà c'est tout après c'est sûr
que si on s'évertue à rendre toutes
postées d'accord toujours plus complexes
c'est dommage mais aujourd'hui la
question qui se pose c'est oui ou non
acceptons ce bloc populaire accessible
au second tour alors je vous le dis le
l'accroissement de la participation
populaire l'effet efficacité du vote
peut fonctionner d'ailleurs cette
dynamique de campagne elle se vérifie
mais c'est clair qu'aujourd'hui en
l'état actuel des sondages tels qu'ils
nous sont présentés si nous étions
ensemble comme nous l'étions en 2012 en
2017 on seraient aux portes de ce second
dernière question parce que ma voix que
le temps le temps tournait et l'asthme
est ce que vous serez candidat à la roue
législatives dans la première
circonscription du nord alors si je dois
être candidat ce sera évidemment dans la
première circonscription du nord
maintenant je me prononcerai sur les
législatives le moment venu parce que on
se concentre d'abord sur la diren
emmanuel macron oui oui oui oui leur vie
je l'aimé chaque chose en son temps et
je ferai vraiment l'erreur serait
d'enjamber l'élection présidentielle non
nous nous croyons que dans moins de 65 m
il ya une opportunité pour se qualifier
au second tour
[Musique]